if you had to go back would you change
your Vote or you'd still vote for Biden
I've never voted before in my life
you've never voted I've never voted why
is this you don't think you have impact
as one person or
why haven't you
I can't see in the family A little bit
of both you don't think your vote has I
mean I know that's like not not cool you
know it's not cool it's a privilege to
vote people die for our right to vote
I've just never voted but also if you
have a foreign
yeah it is I mean I've never cared
enough to actually [ __ ] register and
go down the polls it does I've never
voted you know I also just [ __ ] hate
politics which is funny because it
doesn't seem like it right now yeah
exactly you're very outspoken but
let me push back a little bit brother
because you're very outspoken you have
very hardcore beliefs you're not shy at
all
doesn't you know voting kind of gives
you the right to be vocal if you don't
vote that's that's your right to be
vocal I'm not proud how do you grapple
with that I'm not proud of the fact that
I've never voted maybe I will vote this
next time
but that's the truth I haven't I've
never voted for anybody in my life for
anything
that's got my opinion I just have my
voice but I feel like your voice is more
important than the vote I feel like if
more people started using their [ __ ]
voice
then uh you know
we might not be so respectful I don't
know about that bro because if everyone
just talks [ __ ] but didn't vote then
then we wouldn't have it Alexa yeah I
see I see your point I see your point I
mean I I ideally you should use your
voice and vote yeah right yeah exactly
especially if you have strong opinions
like the ones you do especially if uh
yeah if your sandwich because what you
just said is not very popular in the
state you ran uh and by the way what's
keeping you in California why are you
still staying in California it's my home
it's my home
I'm not going anywhere else it's my home
what needs to happen there for you to
leave nothing
[ __ ] I mean I'm from Iran bro and that's
my home but I'm in U.S right now so you
know I I can I can see a lot of people
who are immigrants in U.S who were born
elsewhere
yeah I mean that's a good question I
don't know I don't think I'll ever leave
I love the I I love la I love la I love
I love but when you see what Garcetti
and Newsome are doing there must be some
point we're like all right homeless
everywhere mandates everywhere just [ __ ]
on the streets it's getting annoying
wokism yeah at some point you're like
all right yeah like if someone does this
like you always do this like do this do
this at some point you're gonna spazz
out and freak out right there must be a
Tipping Point at some point yeah well I
guess I'm just hoping that [ __ ] gets
better
maybe if you voted yeah I mean that's
valid that's valid you know what I'm
saying I I you're like you're checking
me a little bit but but you're right
honestly right because I it's a
privilege to [ __ ] vote and I've never
and I've never utilized it so I
appreciate that here's what's gonna
happen when you vote whether you vote
left or right you're gonna walk in the
booth
and other than you know president vice
president governor there's going to be
all the props and [ __ ] yeah dude good
luck reading that good luck
understanding that a pretty educated
well-versed person and I struggle
understanding these voting amendments
whatever they are yeah propositions
struggle yeah so if you're the average
person and the way that they word these
bills and amendments and propositions
you don't know what the hell you're
walking into yeah so imagine you're the
average person you're just checking left
right up then now you're voting for
justices and yeah Congress people you've
never heard of and director of
Agriculture you're just checking [ __ ]
boxes yeah you know it's crazy I never
had any intention of of speaking on
anything politically coming up here
today that's how it happened I don't
know where right off the bat yeah I had
no intention uh I I try to avoid
politics but you know if it happens
naturally then the older you get the
more it matters the older especially you
got you got a daughter I mean you got
you got a you got a family now so the
way you vote impacts is there anybody in
mind you have that if they ran in 2024
they would earn your vote I have no idea
you're not following anything no I'm not
following anything none of it really
okay so did you see what happened I just
go off what I see you know what I'm
saying I just go off of what I see and I
call a spade a spade so if you like this
clip and you want to watch another one
click right here and if you want to
watch the entire podcast click right
here
[Music]